Disney's original Little Mermaid came
out in 1989 and even though I was five
at the time something really bothered me
about this movie yes it was the legal
contract I was an extremely litigious
five-year-old So today we're gonna make
that little boy very happy we're gonna
talk about whether Ariel's contract with
Ursula the Sea Witch where Ariel trades
her voice for legs in an effort to win
the kiss of True Love from a human that
she just met earlier that day and who
doesn't know that she exists because you
know Disney is a legally enforceable
contract and the answer may surprise you
and for those of you who didn't jump
onto Wikipedia before clicking on this
video here's a quick refresher of what
happened in The Little Mermaid cartoon
now once upon a time there was Ariel a
16 year old mermaid princess of the
underwater Kingdom of Atlantica who had
grown tired of her life Under the Sea
[Music]
now we're going to ignore the fact that
she is a 16 year old through most of
this Tale But Ariel's father and a ruler
of Atlantica at King Triton has
forbidden contact between myrrh people
and humans and orders Ariel to away from
the surface World they are dangerous do
you think I want to see my youngest
daughter snared by some fish eater's
hook and I am never never to hear of you
going to the surface again is that clear
but since daughters who listen to their
fathers don't exactly make for good
movies Ariel disobeys her father and
swims to the surface she sees Prince
Eric celebrating his birthday and by the
laws of Disney she falls instantaneously
in love and I know I said we were going
to ignore the fact that Ariel is 16 But
Eric looks conservatively to be
celebrating his 35th birthday here now
that's when a terrible storm hits Prince
Eric is thrown overboard and is then
rescued by Ariel
when her father finds out Ariel not only
rescued a human from drowning but is in
love with him uh an outraged King Triton
destroys Ariel's Grotto of human
artifacts devastating her this in
retrospect seems way more abusive than
it did 25 years ago and just a small bit
of unsolicited advice do not take
parenting tips from Disney movies I
don't care if you're upset you do not
destroy your teenager's entire Grotto of
misunderstood human artifacts now
theoretically someone might need to call
Mer Child Protective Services on King
Triton but that's a topic for a
different video and it's with Triton's
opening that Ursula sees the opportunity
to begin contract negotiations with
Ariel now immediately after Triton's
destruction of The Grotto Ursula's two
moray eels Flotsam and Jetsam pounce on
a crying aerial like a credit card
company on a college freshman don't be
scared we represent someone who can help
you someone who can make all your dreams
come through and the eels are acting as
agents of their principal Ursula this
all checks out in a principal Asian
relationship the agent has legal
authority to speak and act on behalf of
another which can include the power to
negotiate contracts here Flotsam and
Jetsam have declared that they represent
Ursula the Sea Witch and have the
authority to communicate on her behalf
so far so good now pursuant to that
Authority they have invited Ariel to
meet with Ursula to negotiate an
agreement though for some reason the
screenwriters did not decide to phrase
it in that way now Ariel then follows
the eels back to Ursula's Lair where the
sea witch details the terms of their
proposed agreement in song
[Music]
Ursula is expressing her intention to
make a deal with Ariel and communicates
these specific terms and consideration
of the proposed agreement Ursula offers
to make Ariel a human for three days in
exchange for aerial giving Ursula uh her
voice and if Ariel does not receive the
kiss of True Love from Prince Eric
within three days then she reverts back
to a mermaid and shall belong to Ursula
inciting past historical precedent of
previous parties who failed to perform
under their contracts Ursula
demonstrates what it means to belong to
her and once or twice someone couldn't
pay the price and I'm afraid I had to
wake him across the goals
aerial will be transformed into a polyp
and forced to live in Ursula's Garden
for the rest of her life so from these
circumstances from both an objective and
subjective perspective one would
conclude that Ursula wants to enter into
a contract with Ariel and also both
parties can claim to receive some
benefit out of this agreement Ariel gets
legs and Ursula gets an incredible voice
and potentially Ariel's Eternal Soul
totally equal consideration is a
requirement for a contract so we have a
legally sufficient offer supported by
valid consideration now while acceptance
of an offer can be shown through conduct
the most common way to Signal acceptance
is through signing a document to
indicate that you agree to be bound by
the terms of that contract now here
Ursula makes clear that the contract
will only be valid if Ariel signs the
scroll which Ariel then does now for a
contract to be valid you're looking for
a meeting of the minds you could sign
sometimes you could just verbally say
yes or sometimes your verbal offer and
acceptance could be in song that could
be totally valid too but hold on a
second Ariel can read and write I mean I
know she gave up her voice but later on
in the movie why didn't she just take
out a piece of paper and write dear Eric
I'm the mermaid who saved you a sea
witch took my voice and I had problems
with my father Let's Get Married give me
a kiss and all this goes away due to a
business business contracts XOXO Ariel
that would have saved a whole bunch of
time and it probably would have worked I
mean when's the last time that sailor
Eric even saw a woman but I digress now
so far this movie is a bit of a train
wreck or shipwreck but if you got into
an actual train wreck or car wreck Which
is far more likely you'll probably need
a great lawyer one who wouldn't have let
16 year old Ariel sign this contract now
my firm the eagle team is accepting new
clients and you're entitled to a free
consultation if you've been injured we
want to help or if you need a lawyer for
anything that's not under the sea we can
represent you or help you find the right
attorney because you don't need a legal
team you need the eagle team just check
out the link in the description so now
let's think like a lawyer and let's see
if we can get out of this stupid
contract so now we have established the
basic elements of a contract we look at
whether the contract itself is legally
enforceable and as you'll see Ariel
probably has multiple Avenues in which
she could have invalidated or at the
very minimum modify the contract due to
potentially fatal defects in its
formation now first a contract is
considered ambiguous if the material
turns the contract are reasonably
subject to more than one interpretation
typically due to a specific word or
phrase that's vague or unclear one red
flag is a condition that Ariel must
receive a kiss of true love within three
days to remain human now notwithstanding
the weird Disney Trope of falling in
love in three days the term kiss of true
love is probably an amorphous
ill-defined term uh Concept in the law
now does Ariel have to marry Prince Eric
within three days will just one smooch
fulfill the contract how do you even
prove that it's true love versus Teenage
infatuation and who decides whether a
kiss is a kiss of true love now it seems
like true love is determined by Disney
Magic which I believe in by the way for
all of you weird adult Disney fans out
there please don't swap me but in the
non-magical realm courts can look to a
variety of sources to clarify the
party's intentions regarding ambiguous
terms such as common usage the party's
negotiations or you know the judge can
simply decide whether one interpretation
would be more reasonable than the other
and in most jurisdictions ambiguities
are typically resolved against the party
that drafted the contract so that's good
news for Ariel If This Were a contract
in a world where the terms are enforced
by the courts and not by Disney Magic uh
you know a judge would likely settle on
the most reasonable interpretation of
Kiss of true love uh judging by the
party's negotiations a reasonable
interpretation might be a kiss that
signals the intention that Ariel and
Prince Eric want to get married
um though Ariel is 16 so normally she
could get married at that age without
parental consent but maybe Atlantica is
off the coast of Alabama or something
Alabama
I don't know but speaking of which that
takes us to capacity because in order to
enter into a valid contract parties to
an agreement must have what is known as
legal capacity to the contra now that
means the parties have to have a mental
ability to understand and consent to the
terms of an agreement examples of those
who lack capacity to contract are those
who lack the legal competence due to
physical or mental disability or those
who have entered into agreement well
intoxicated also important here in most
jurisdictions contracts signed by minors
are voidable meaning that the miner can
either honor the deal or choose to
disaffirm the contract until they turn
the age of 18 years old which is the
most common age of majority and a minor
that disaffirms a contract must return
any consideration to the other party so
here Ariel was 16 years old when she
entered it in the contract even though
the three-day period elapsed Ariel would
still have the power to cancel the
agreement and free herself from Ursula
now I know what you're thinking Ursula
is a magic sea witch is a lawyer really
more powerful than someone who can wield
actual Magic
yes yes lawyers are more powerful than a
magic sewage and as you can see here the
power to disaffirm a contract is
exclusive to the minor as the party to
the contract and in the absence of a
parent co-signing the document the
parent is not liable for the contracts
made by a minor child and of course the
minor child can't be held to that
contract if they choose to disaffirm
again
I want to emphasize this lawyers are
more powerful than a magic sea witch now
of course instead of opening up a
dialogue with his child and exercising
the rights to disaffirm a contract uh
King Triton just substitutes himself in
for the place of Ariel which goes to
show you that you should actively talk
to your children but also you should
always talk to an attorney sometimes
both now uh what you've seen here is
what would be called a Novation a
Novation is an agreement between two
Contracting parties to allow for the
substitution of a new party for an
existing one now the new party will then
be bound by the contract while the
replace Contracting party will be
relieved of all further obligations
however both original Contracting
parties must agree to the substitution
to be valid and here Ariel is very
clearly not approving of the
substitution which makes this Novation
totally invalid and in the absence of
aerial approving The Innovation this
substitution would not be legally
binding on Triton now on top of that
there is the question of
unconscionability uh even if we fix the
issues of ambiguity and capacity and for
some reason a lot of this crazy Novation
between father and daughter now Ariel's
contract provides such harsh terms that
uh that's probably not legally valid the
the terms for non-performance
transforming her into a polyp to live
and Ursula's underwater Garden for hell
for the rest of her life there's no way
that any Court would ever allow that to
stand but the question is why and that
brings us to the concept of
unconscionability for example the
California Supreme Court has described
the unconscionability doctrine as being
concerned not with a simple
old-fashioned bad bargain but with terms
that are unreasonably favorable to the
more powerful party in other words
courts will enforce a contract that's
just bad for someone and not substitute
in their own judgment for the
Contracting party but they will not
enforce contracts that are overly harsh
unduly oppressive or so one-sided as to
shock the conscience and in making a
determination about unconscionability
courts look to both the substantive
aspects of contract like do the terms of
the agreement substantially benefit one
party over another does one party have
unequal bargaining power over the other
and does the contract hide material
terms and find print as well as the
procedural aspects leading to the
contract did the complaining party have
had it with time resources or knowledge
to fully understand what they were
agreeing to and of course here there's
lots of elements that point to the
contract being unconscionable here
Ursula is clearly sophisticated in Magic
and magical contracts while Ariel has no
such knowledge and zero common sense
making Ariel easy to manipulate and
Ursula did not even recommend that Ariel
could consult a myrrh lawyer first who
could have helped to explain the
lifelong ramifications of the agreement
though honestly Ursula didn't exactly
hide the bad terms in fine print for all
eternity jumps off the page as well as
you know the rest of the contract but
Ursula doesn't give Ariel much time to
think about her options and in one
four-minute song Ursula successfully
pressures a 16 year old girl who is
clearly vulnerable impressionable and
Blinded By An need for approval after
having been mistreated by her father
into signing a contract where Ariel's
non-performance will allow Ursula to
take literal ownership of Ariel for
basically eternity and also and I
probably don't need to point this out
it's illegal to own another person you
cannot enter into a contract that
relates to ownership of another person
involuntary servitude was not legal in
the 1830s in Denmark and it's not legal
in the United States today unless you're
in prison and on that basis any effort
to take literal ownership of Ariel for
non-performance would be unenforceable
and then on top of it let's just look at
the actual contract here it's complete
gibberish it's full of fine print that
Ariel clearly does not read Because
Ursula cajols her into signing before
the song ends and when the camera Zooms
in on the fine print it's written in
some unintelligible language I mean even
more unintelligible than a normal legal
contract now I understand that animation
is expensive but couldn't they have at
least put some actual words on the
contract I mean there's clearly a
drawing of Mickey Mouse in the middle of
a sentence here now if a court
determines that the contract is
unconscionable the court can do three
things first it can void the entire
contract as it never existed and make
the parties return any benefits to each
other so Ariel would get her voice back
and turn back into a mermaid second the
court could just void the unconscionable
terms and keep the rest of the contract
so you'd probably strike the enslavement
provision and Ariel would revert to
being a mermaid for non-performance and
then third the court could uphold the
entire contract while modifying the
unconscionable terms likely the same
effect as voiding the unconscionable
terms but I don't know maybe Ariel would
then stay a human in that case but
regardless there's no way for Ariel's
contract to be enforceable in its
current form and on top of that even
contract was was enforceable Ariel's
non-performance could absolutely be
excused because Ursula meddled in her
performance of the contract and this
could have actual real world
implications because every contract
imposes upon each party and implied duty
of good faith and fair dealing in the
performance and enforcement a party
breaches these duties when their conduct
actively interferes with the other
party's attempts to fulfill their
obligations and here behind the scenes
we can see that Ursula is secretly
working to stop Ariel from performing
under the agreement by preventing Ariel
from receiving a kiss of true love but
for Ursula's interference Ariel likely
would have received a kiss of true love
within a three-day period as required by
the contractual terms and as a result of
Ursula's bad faith actions aerial would
be excused for her non-performance and
would not have reverted back to a
mermaid at the end of the third day and
Ursula would be liable to Ariel for all
damages caused by her interference
that's if Ariel had had a good lawyer
from the very start to battle this
magical sea witch but basically this is
a very defective contract that no one in
their right mind would have signed and
Ursula doesn't make matters better by
actively trying to stop Ariel from
performing now Ariel clearly lacks some
basic critical thinking skills but if
you'd like to be smarter than air Ariel
and Bone upon your logic math and
science skills you can do that with
today's sponsor brilliant because not
everyone can be a 16 year old Heir
Apparent to a sea Kingdom brilliant is
the best way to learn math and computer
science interactively brilliant is an
online learning platform for stem that
replaces lecture videos with Hands-On
interactive lessons it's for Curious
Learners both young and old professional
and inexperienced you can quickly learn
to Ace your high school or college math
courses or just learn stuff that you
always wanted to brilliant helps you
reach your goals whether you're a
student or a professional looking to get
ahead for example their new how
technology Works course teaches you the
inner workings of everyday technology
from video compression GPS and computer
memory and another one of my favorite
courses is all about logic Brilliance
logic courses cover liar and Truth
teller riddles logical fallacies machine
logic and even some strategic game
theory logic is of course a critical
skill that lawyers need every day and
Brilliant lets you learn by doing rather
than listening to hours of boring
lectures it's all interactive and fun so
you can sign up and start learning for
free today by going to brilliant.org
legaleagle or by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description if you click on that
link you'll get a free 30-day trial plus
the first 200 people who sign up will
get 20 off their annual subscription so
by clicking on the link below you'll get
a free 30-day trial and 20 off your
annual subscription to brilliant after
that click on this link over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court